the countdown was on for an enormous
year
this time Big Ben playing an even bigger
part
fireworks are first for the famous clock
tower
twelve thousand fireworks lit up the
skies blasting London into 2012
the City Olympic rings above the London
Eye hinting at the big 12 months that
lie ahead
seven hours earlier the crowds had
started gathering water of a million
people lining the Thames which I found
the square some traveling across the
globe there's the party a very
international field
Czech Republic to see the fireworks and
enjoy the party just for this night just
for you
it was ridiculously good beyond words
almost thousand people of course turn
out along the embankment to watch the
big event for real but these
celebrations are beamed right around the
world and with the Olympics the
Paralympics and the Diamond Jubilee
coming up it's all about proving that
London could do those big events in
style but he organises the 11 minute
display was more than enough to keep us
up there with the international elite
London is definitely the best fireworks
there is you know it might be a little
bit warmer in Sydney and it might be a
bit colder in New York but ours are
without a doubt the best fireworks in
the world
London had promised an extraordinary
start to the new year
and if this is just the beginning who
can wait the celebrations still to come
in 2012
the animals skynews in central London
wasn't just in England that they were
celebrating
the home of Hogmanay at least if you
live in Edinburgh threw a party there in
the city for 80,000 revelers concerts
from the likes of primal scream kept the
crowds entertained for the Scottish
capitals largest ever firework finale
what did you think of the firework
absolutely fantastic
it was brilliant for Scott under think
coming from Wales was a good weekend for
us yer a pavilion firework I've been to
LA this was never seen